on jette souvent nos choux gras à la
maison comment l'entreprise et pourtant
les résidus de certaines transformation
alimentaire sont encore intéressant et
peuvent servir à créer de nouveaux
produits
[Musique]
granola étudiants biscuits et craquelins
ces aliments sont fabriqués à partir de
déchets de production alimentaire c'est
un déchet mais en fait c'est des
céréales craintes qui ont moins de sucre
dedans donc ces folles nutritifs ses
environs ce composé à 70 % de fibres et
20 % de protéines fac c'est assez
incroyable
qu'on jette c'est
dans cette petite cuisine chloé fils ici
fabrique des craquelins à base de
drèches un résidu de la production de la
bière
[Musique]
[Rires]
si on voit comme ça donc c'est un peu la
texture de duru you c'est vraiment des
serial ses défauts les gens le mode rush
ça leur fait peur on sait pas trop c'est
quoi mais c'est des serial
s'est félicité à développer les recettes
elles incorporent la drêche à la pâte et
on rajoute d'autres et fils pour les
craquelins piment on offre en fait
différentes saveurs qui s'accordent avec
les différents types de bières on
commence à avoir une petite communauté
de revalorisation de la drêche mais la
plupart de la drêche et voilà on se fait
souvent appelé le par des brasseurs de
venir chercher notre drêche on sait pas
quoi faire avec donc c'est vraiment un
problème criant pourquoi ça dit merci
bon je peux l'écrire aussi un peu plus
un peu moins
les craquelins sont composés de farine
des pis comme du sapin baumier du poivre
et 50% de drèches récupérés dans des
micro brasserie de montréal
comme ici à la coopérative brassicole ma
brasserie nous aussi on produit environ
une centaine de tonnes par année de
drèches donc de résidus d'orge ou de
grains mouillé quand qu'on casse les
grains d'orge on les mélange avec de
l'eau chaude pour soutirer les sucres
faire un mot qu'on va faire fermenter en
bière mais ceci te produis le qui reste
il faut une faut s'en débarrasser on
peut pas le garder ici
[Musique]
comme plusieurs brasseurs la coopérative
doit payer un fermier pour qu'ils
viennent récupérer la majorité des
drèches pour nourrir ses animaux malgré
cet effort beaucoup reste à faire la
quantité de déchets de toutes façons la
ville de montréal pour épauler gérer non
plus donc il faut trouver l'ipad n'est
pas beaucoup de solutions saas est un
des enjeux qu'on a c'est le manque de
solutions j'ai vraiment eu un choc parce
que je me disais qu'ils aient la bière
c'est tellement quelque chose de
plaisant une belle industrie phone je
savais pas ok environ voient une pinte
de bière qui une plainte de recherche
qui écrit donc moi je peux pas
considérer quelque chose que dès que les
enzymes que des protéines que les sucs
dedans comme un déchet donc tout
simplement ses sagas nourriture oui
c'est très bon
s'est à peine salée oui on utilise du
sel de terre neuve cédric boutons comme
c'est votre goodyear du tout là haut
comme il ya peut-être un goût de
céréales ouais mais c'est pas mal sauf
ça goûte la drêche
d'autres entreprises ont la même mission
dans cette usine de tofu on récupère un
autre déchet l'uqar à ça c'est local
c'est la partie fibreuse en fait qu'ils
sentaient lorsqu on fabrique titre fut
ça génère un déchet mais en fait c'est
un déchet pour nous ici par contre au
japon cette échelle qui s'appelle
lokarri faisait déjà depuis longtemps en
fait à faire d'autres aliments avec ça
tout comme la drêche the résidus de
pulpe et de soya est encore très
nutritif et un produit en grande
quantité en termes de quantité d'eau car
est générée par production je voudrais
encaissement du rhin courant sinon un
peu plus présentement
sébastien tétreault s'est associé à
compter à pour trouver des solutions et
développer des produits afin de
revaloriser l'eau car à notre objectif
c'est de revaloriser 100 tonnes de
carottes d'ici un an et demi
actuellement à la fin de l'année on
prévoit finir à 5 tonnes
il ajoute de l'eau kara dans la croûte
d'une pizza propose du tofu brouillé
avec de l'eau car à ce qui ajoute de la
texture mais aussi des fibres des
vitamines à sa gamme de produits
végétalien la mission de voyages lycée
vraiment de réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire on commence avec justement
des fèves de soya dont finir à zéro
émission en termes de déchets un
canadien sur sept souffre d'insécurité
alimentaire dont pour nous ça faisait
aucun sens d'acheter cette matière là
qui est super nutritive encore puis
aussi parce que les gaspillage
alimentaire responsable des gaz à effet
de serre en grosse partie donc très
bénéfique pour l'environnement tourné en
2022 ça fait longtemps qu'on gaspille
long on pense vraiment que ses lutins de
changer nos façons de consommer des plus
conscients faut encourager les petites
entreprises qui veulent sortir d'une
forme d'économie connu pour aller dans
une économie plus petit circulaire mais
qui fait un sens on peut pas y arriver
seul il faut vraiment plusieurs
entreprises petites ou grandes qui
contribuent au phénomène pour pouvoir
avoir un impact si mme catic parce que
les aliments mangés extrêmement beaucoup
au canada